une meilleure connaissance de l'économie
sociale rendrait les jeunes plus enclins
à envisager de se lancer en affaires
selon un sondage mené par la firme léger
pour mieux faire connaître cette façon
d'entreprendre le chantier de l'économie
sociale lance un réseau de 19 nouveaux
incubateur d'entreprises collectives
destinées aux étudiants de niveau post
secondaires du québec avec nous pour en
parler
béatrice allain directeur général du
chantier de l'économie sociale et adrien
sirois cournoyer cofondatrice de la
coopérative ingénierie halte co-op
bonsoir bonsoir à vous deux
ça alors d'abord madame allez vous
lancer cela parce que vous avez constaté
qu'il ya une méconnaissance de
l'économie sociale oui en effet quand on
est allé sonder les jeunes sur ben e
est-ce qu'ils avaient une volonté
d'entreprendre oui on trouve que ce
qu'ils ont mais reconnaissance
d'économie sociale ont plus de volonté
d'entreprendre ce qui pour moi parle du
fait que ça rend peut-être plus
accessible l'entrepreneuriat mais aussi
pour voir les valeurs ce qu'est ce qui
les intéressait dans un milieu de
travail
puis le fait d'avoir un mot à dire dans
la gestion de servir la communauté de ce
souci de son impact environnemental
c'est tout des considérations qui sont
très proches des structures mêmes de la
raison d'être des entreprises d'économie
sociale
or ces raisons de cette façon de
fonctionner est peu connue des jeunes
parce qu'on enseigne pas d'économie
sociale au québec exact mal les écoles
on n'enseigne pas ce que c'est malgré
que c'est une réalité très importante
pour l'économie du québec pour parler de
la société c'est peu connu mais peu
enseignée dans les écoles
dans ce sondage au jeu 6-2 chiffres du
sondage 47% disent avoir un bon niveau
de connaissances chez les jeunes de 18 à
34 ans de l'économie sociale oui la 40e'
est quand même pas pire mais 15% sont
capables de vraiment répondre à toutes
les questions qui leur sont posées
- sur l'économie on est en fait beaucoup
dans un peu des préjugés défavorables
donc on pense que l'économie sociale
c'est nécessairement que dans certains
secteurs alors que c'est vraiment une
façon d'entreprendre qui peut être
adapté à tous les secteurs d'activité ou
que ce sont des petites entreprises mal
payés et toutes les statistiques
démontrent que c'est pas le cas que
c'est plutôt une façon d'entreprendre
autrement en cohérence avec ses valeurs
et de s'impliquer au service de la
communauté abriel sirois cornouaille et
vous êtes co fondatrice de la première
coopérative d'ingénérie au québec donc
dans l'économie sociale sous le titre
coopératif pourquoi vous avez choisi
cela oui donc à la base on s'est
rencontré il gagne d'étudiants justement
d'ingénieur puis nous on trouvait pas
notre place dans le milieu l'ingénierie
en prépa notre notre espace de travail
justement parce qu'on avait des valeurs
très bons liens avec eux l'économie
sociale donc dialogue social et
environnemental puis on était huit
autour d'une terme puis pour nous ça
faisait du sens de faire ça de manière
collective puis en créant une
coopérative de travailleurs en fait à
bon en fait créé un espace de travail
pour des futurs ingénieurs pour leur
donner une voix puis en fait très peur
des projets avec les dix ans pour eux
parce que donne l'économie actuellement
dans le fonctionnement
vous ne trouviez pas un endroit qui
était adaptée à ce que vous cherchiez
oui exactement donc nous on voulait
faire des projets vraiment ancré dans
les communautés on avait on voulait
faire des projets en participant
écologique avec des valeurs très
environnementale mais on avait aussi un
désir d'être très autonome dans notre
projet donc nous l'autonomie est une
question fondamentale
puis en créant de quoi on avait on
devenait vraiment porteur du projet puis
aussi on aurait protégé une mission
sociale qui allait perdurer dans le
temps donc c'est vraiment ce qui est
important pour nous puis
après on était plus ingénieur puis un
numéro dans une entreprise on était
vraiment comme l'entrepreneur de ce
projet là puis on avait une voix ça
donne du sens en tout cas et les
questions de valeurs sont importantes je
veux présenter un autre extrait du
sondage que vous avez menées d'abord 36%
de suivre des jeunes disent on veut
devenir entrepreneur en économie sociale
n'ont en général général et ça c'est
auprès de la population générale mais
ceux qui sont qui connaissent mieux
l'économie sociale ont un taux
d'intention plus élevé plus élevés et
vos réponses
ceux qui s'intéressent à l'économie
sociale on veut ça parce qu'on veut
rendre la société meilleure on veut plus
d'autonomie vous l'avez mentionné dans
les tâches la vie habilités de ce qu'on
fait avant le trophy absolument on veut
répondre aux besoins de la communauté
vous l'avez mentionné aussi améliorer
l'environnement
c'est vraiment une question de valeurs
qui étaient associés à l'économie
sociale
mais en fait ce qui est intéressant est
un peu frustrant c'est que ça c'est tous
les jeunes qui ont ces valeurs là mais
sans connaître nécessairement le
véhicule qui est l'entrepreneuriat
collectif qui leur permet de faire ça
dans les fêtes
ouais donc on voit si elle allait faire
tout le temps chez les jeunes
aujourd'hui qui pensent peut-être les
jeunes aujourd'hui plus je pense qu'on
est tous confrontés aux limites de la
croissance des inégalités sociales la
question environnementale qui m'a
j'appuie tout le monde est saisie de
l'importance de faire les choses
autrement et je pense que cet exemple là
que non seulement à travers le travail
qui livre que livre la co op
mais la façon dont ils yves ce travail
ont fait autrement on génère une
intelligence collective puis une
redevabilité qui est différent et donc
vous lancer un programme s'appelle 6 mai
qu'exhale exactement 6 mai que c'est un
parcours qui va mener des jeunes donc
c'est des jeunes moins de 35 ans dans
les universités surtout qu'ils ont une
idée de soi quelque chose qu'ils
aimeraient faire ou a besoin dans la
communauté on va les amener à préciser
cette équipe
cette idée là identifie l'équipe qui va
gérer c'est donc l'équipe
entreprenariale a commencé un modèle
d'affaires et ensuite on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de structures de soutien soit
en économie sociale ou à haut niveau
territorial donc ils vont être relayées
vers ces structures là pour peaufiner
puis avancé mais ça répond à un premier
besoin de faciliter l'émergence
deux projets entre liddes et puis le
projet viable présenté pour
investissement et vous dans ce que vous
avez fait jusqu'à maintenant est ce
qu'une réalisation en particulier que
vous pouvez nous donner un exemple avec
la coopérative donc par exemple on ne
fait un projet tout récemment est encore
dans sur la côte nord dans une
communauté autochtone donc on les a
accompagnés dans la mise en place d'un
projet de compostage donc dans cette
canopée leur puis on a aussi des projets
en bâtiment écologique donc on
accompagne les particuliers ou des
entreprises qui veulent construire de
manière différente
probablement avec des énergies
renouvelables inspiré de principe
influence en sait trop mais qui font du
sens aujourd'hui
l'intéressant on doit s'arrêter ou est
ce conseil forme sur le programme sur le
site du chantier oui il ya une page
dédiée à 6 mais qui va référés vers
aussi toutes les structures parce que ça
se déploie dans toutes les régions du
québec donc c'est avec l'épaule
d'économie sociale mais tout se trouve
sur le site chantier chantier point
qc.ca voilà on le met en bas d'écran
béatrice alain abriel sirois cournoyer
merci beaucoup